The answer is Error: incompatible types. A Dog is not a kind of House. If you
try to store a Dog in a variable that's made to hold a House, you'll get a
compile time error, which is good. If Java let you store a Dog in a House
variable, you might then try to call House methods on the Dog. And the Dog
wouldn't know how to do them. Getting this error is actually a good thing. It
means that java is helping us. This is one of the things that we were talking
about when we mentioned really early on that java is a safe language. If java
let you create a Dog and then store it as a House, you might try to live in it
later and fail. But instead of doing that, the compiler will immediately tell
you that there's something wrong with your code. Other languages might allow
you to keep running the code, and then mysteriously fail or return the wrong
results. This third option isn't quite what we want. This the area that you
would get if Dog were an interface. If you tried to make a new Drawable, then
you would get an error like this. Error Drawable is abstract cannot be
instantiated. The Drawable interface has methods sort of, but it doesn't have
enough detail about them for Java to actually make an object Drawable for you.